kelly slater accès aux quais c'est pas
mal ça ça vibre beaucoup un écoute mais
je ne sais pas la sig en bac on peut le
voir au caire mais c'est pas mal cet âge
là ouais elle rappelé sur le village
maintenant qu'on passe le 7 mai c'est
bien on va bien que toi il on s'est
vraiment désertifier ils sont pas bila
exprès là où il n'y a plus rien il
entend couper les coins un îlot ikoku
dans le se veut quoi couper ce fait
divers c'est complètement suicidaire et
après ils vont taper un peu plus loin at
on à paris quoi un c'est un taux dans ma
part y ont trouvé des interférences sur
bali genre que des quadri pas mal ça
ouais c'est bien de le voir chez
impression que ça vivre un peu ce que je
dois d'en bas lapins pigeons l'instant
par la ccit des requins pick up des
parcours en coupe
ce qu'il ya autour de chez toi et laisse
le filet comme ça confie 10 sur le grand
talent
je n'ai pas vu leur santé
là on pense qu elles deux fois et chaque
instant